you are like a franchise clean right now
I realize yes I mean Marvel Mission
Impossible and now transform our
transform how does that feel for you I
love it I didn't plan it I promise you
but worked out that way it just worked
out that way
well it worked out that way because
you're incredibly talented I mean but
how did it feel for you when you found
out that this was locked in you could
say I'm gonna be a villain at
transformers oh that was exciting that
was thrilling the idea you know earth
finally able to play a villain yeah you
know cuz that's something that I've been
asking for and transformer has been
around you know it's not generally like
where I go cuz I want heart I want story
I want emotion but in this one they they
give you that they give you that you
know with Charlie with bumblebee but
they also put the transformer fans fans
so speak epic you know you get that also
at there so it's be a truly satisfied
there's a war raging on our planet
if this criminal isn't found that war
may find its way
did you mess with your voice at all for
the movie or did they take all of that
take care of all that for you because it
has a low like reverb or something even
I was important to me you know how
hearing your own voice sometimes sounds
odd to you but I liked it and then they
did a little something to it I have to
reverb or something gave it some extra
it's fear Howard gravitas
honestly everything about they I know
she's a villain but I was thinking she's
a badass shisui fierceness Decepticon
she's running things she's in charge of
everybody telling that guy what to do
did you like having that power I like
that yeah she's uh what I would call it
not a triple threat like a triple
changer you know what though she is
threat right a triple threat oh my god
like how are you personally a triple
threat because we know you are what
makes you a triple threat oh my god let
me see fierce friend mm-hmm awesome mom
hot wife and your dress today to match
the fierceness of your Decepticon
character how speaking of being an
amazing mom and a hot wife how did the
fam react to you getting a Transformers
role oh my gosh they're so excited
especially my son and my daughter you
know she wants she wants a yellow
comfort a yellow vwf vintage beetle she
wants one of those how can I find
do they have one of them this wagon
probably a little one but I think she
wants the real deal I got a couple of
years for that Oh sounds like I don't
get it with all this technology now why
would you want some rain
vintage she's an old soul she is he is
she likes some nitro and all of the
Christmas songs so this is her stanza
they're twins yeah
and he's just you know crack logic okay
kind of thing okay so they're protecting
ology have they seen the movie yet are
you gonna watch you haven't seen it yeah
okay see well you kind of watch them
watch it in every action awesome
[Music]
Black Panther getting that golden globes
love how did that feel for you to learn
that's a thrill yeah that's a thrill
that's the dream come true and that's
just the beginning of yeah so deserved
did you do you guys to have like where
were the text blowing up between you and
the cast Oh males the animals the text
did anybody really freak out what was
the best reaction no no I just humbled
by it really yeah just just humbled and
I'm just grateful because I think it's
just so right well we know that Ryan
Coogler is working on the sequel do you
know anything about it a thing has he
told you anything even if you can't tell
us is he given you know I don't know how
deep he's off into it yet I think he's
gathering his thoughts together I think
it's coming together you still you know
you it lives here for a minute before it
you know well anything you would like to
see happen I mean being so entrenched in
it all in the cast being so close
anything you'd like to see the sequel do
I want to see Ramon de go back to some
dwarma logy days when she was maybe she
was in the dorm a lot she and she could
fight a little bit yes it's really good
another badass moment for you we'll take
it also have to ask you about I mean he
had another franchise that people love
you in American Horror Story so Ryan
Murphy told us the coven is coming back
he told the era is Walk of Fame he told
what you were at and so he's what the
witches are coming back coming back
again
yeah
do you know something you can't what
sounds like you the end but I know
somebody I mean you were at yeah there's
no what you know it's who you know it
sounds like you'd be down to come back
yeah I mean I love doing this someone
showed me a clip from it today it's just
like more of it well what would if you
were gonna come back what would you want
to do Murray yeah
but anything specific that you're like
who I want to try this or I want to have
this happen oh I love that and you know
with the with everything that's been
happening for Black Panther I mean do
you guys have your sights set on I I
know it's but would you like to see some
Oscars love for it do you think that
could have on it with Nick yeah
absolutely
I think that's a good place to start
that's a good place to start I mean
where there's the production design
supporting it yes yes yes please and
when you were you thinking about just
this movie what people are gonna love
about it why would you say go see a
movie there's something for the entire
family really it's a lot of heart like
those transformer fans we
stunning amazing mind-blowing action
sequences there's plenty of that for you
it's funny fun stuff how does the family
get when they go and see like one of
your movies go from all I get a couple
of days of like some mommy loves her
Bobby love respect what about you man
he's got a big new [ __ ] you said hot
white lady and she changes into a I mean
and with with doing this movie but you
guys are about to go I think yeah you've
been were you and Europe for the press
tour tour Yvonne hong kong's
but premier tomorrow
how are you gonna feel when you're
stepping on that carpet Oh wonderful
yeah yeah a great into a phenomenal
[Music]